well brian we've shown you a number of
these pop-up clinics around the valley
but one tonight may be really the most
vegas shots were given under the famous
welcome to las vegas sign
madison kimbrough is live from the
iconic landmark tonight in madison i
hear there was a pretty good turnout too
denise it was a convenient way for
locals and visitors to get their shot
the line started forming
even before they officially open take a
look
we want to get back to normal life we
don't have our masks on i just want to
live the urge to get back to normalcy
is apparent as more and more people
choose to get vaccinated
today visitors and locals partook in a
pop-up clinic event
held at the welcome to fabulous las
vegas sign
people visiting vegas thought it was a
pretty cool idea to have an event like
this
at such a well-known spot i'm in the
healthcare field
and i know a lot of people with work
schedules haven't had the opportunity to
get it
and they have planned vacation and it
would be like
a good idea for them to just get it
while they're on vacation i think the
easier you make it for people to get it
they may be more willing to do it
if i'm here and i can step out of line
get it i think people are more likely
the pop-up vaccination clinic opened at
7 p.m and lasted until
10 p.m hosted by immunized nevada it was
open to those 12 and older and the
pfizer and jansen vaccine were both
available
many locals were also pretty pleased
with the options given
i decided to go with the one shot so
that i can just be
one and done it was very quick and
simple i wanted the one in one
i myself i live four miles away i don't
drive
so this was a perfect location for me i
just took the bus over here
and in addition to the shot there was an
on-site photographer on
hand to snap pics of everyone who got
vaccinated
and even elvis himself made an
appearance
now the event was hosted by the county
and there were several city officials in
attendance
toro university of nevada is the college
that provided the staff to administer
these shots
reporting live from the las vegas sign
madison kimbrough 8 news